did Prince Harry just get a preview of
what his son Archie will look like in a
few years about three weeks after the 34
year old royal and his wife Megan Markel
welcomed their first child Harry stepped
out solo to attend the opening match of
the ICC Cricket World Cup in London
before the game here he met with a group
of kids including one boy who seriously
looks like a younger version of Harry
there he is rocking a blue baseball cap
and t-shirt but it was his freckles and
red hair that could not be missed you
guys and it seems like Harry and Megan
might have noticed the similarities to
they shared a ton of pics from the
outing on their Instagram page including
a close-up shot of the princes mini-me
let's do a side-by-side shall we
young Harry on the Left look like on the
right I'm here for it Harry's Minnie
doppelganger wasn't the only thing
people were talking about at the
sporting event which was part of a
six-week tournament featuring the
world's top 10 cricket teams 9 of which
represent Commonwealth countries Harry
also shared a powerful speech at the
opening game between South Africa and
England the first ever Cricket World Cup
took place in England in 1975 and I'm
delighted that the UK will once again
play host to this wonderful global
sporting event featuring 10 incredible
teams who thanks to the UK's cultural
diversity will feel as though they are
competing in front of a home crowd every
time they take to the field next up for
Harry a visit from President Donald
Trump the president arrives in the UK
next week for a state visit and
according to the official schedule for
his upcoming trip he will meet with
Queen Elizabeth Prince Charles and
Camilla and 3/4 of the Fab Four that's
right a source tells ET megan has bowed
out of meeting the Donald of course she
is enjoying maternity leave with her son
Archie who will be less than four weeks
old when the state visit goes down so
she
could be skipping out for that reason
though it is worth noting the 37 year
old new mama has criticized the
president publicly in the past it's
really the moment that I go we film
suits in Toronto and I just stay in
Canada oh right I'm gonna become on like
if that's really the reality that we're
talking about come on that is a
game-changer in terms of how we move in
the world that was Megan during a 2016
interview on the nightly show with Larry
Wilmore talking Trump before he was
elected into office and before she
joined the royal family yes of course
Trump is device and think about just
female voters alone right I mean like he
was in 2012 like the Republican Party
lost the tml book by 12 points that's a
huge number and with this misogynistic
as Trump is and so vocal about it that's
a huge chunk of it you're not just
voting for a woman if it's Hillary just
because she's a woman but certainly
because Trump has made it easy to see
that you don't really want that kind of
world that he's painted already now that
we know how Megan feels I'm not
surprised
she's opting to hang with little Archie
over Trump but I'm really missing all of
her in Harry's cute couple outings are
you guys of course will be here to make
sure you get all the Megan and Harry
news as it rolls in so be sure to keep
it locked on ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]